say those three labor front benches
Jonathan Reynolds Steven dirty and Kevin
Jones it seems that you're sacking has
set the dominoes falling well that those
are individual decisions for the
politicians concerned I've got great
respect for them all but this has been
our decision and I've not encouraged or
suggested to anyone that the that they
do that but that's the decision they've
taken but I mean I've just been talking
in length with mr. Doughty he cites your
your treatments as the reason he went
well I served on the liber front bench
after mr. Corbin became leader because I
thought that was the best thing I could
do in terms of duty to the party and
I've worked with labor all my life fail
my working life going right back to the
days of new clinic and John Smith I've
never rebelled against the labor WEP in
11 years as an MP and I wanted to do my
duty to the party and to the cause of
keeping Britain in the European Union
which is something I feel strongly about
and was my responsibility in policy
terms of shadow Europe minister but the
leader has the right to have a reshuffle
and to change their front bench team if
that's what the leader wants to do and
that's what mr. Corbin has done he
didn't cite when he spoke to me any
reason to do with my front bench
responsibility as Shadow Europe minister
he raised instead issues of statements
I'd made about terrorism fighting
terrorism and the responsibility for
where terrorism lies which he thinks
represents a different view from the one
that he holds yeah but one of the other
reasons the cited maybe not to your face
but by his people whether they they
issued a so-called charge sheet and on
it was an interview you did with me last
year on my sunday show when you warned
about labour and those at the top
turning into a protest group is that the
way it seems to be going now well I
remember that interview and I think you
asked me about protest that was taking
place and protest
has always been part of the labor
tradition goes back a long way and I've
been in a few protest marches myself
over the years but it's not the only
thing that labor is about and I think
what I said to you then and I would say
it again today is that you know our
historical role has been to try to be a
party of government and not see
yourselves only as a protest party and
it's in government when we've built a
broad coalition of voters across the
country that we've done things like
introduce the NHS introduced the minimum
wage the equalities legislation that all
liberal members are proud of its in
government where we've realized our
principles and being able to change the
country for the better and i think
that's always what the Labour Party
should be aiming for so do you think
others are going to go I really don't
know and I'm sad at the situation that's
come about it's not been my decision I I
served enough you know as I say I'm very
loyal to the Labour Party I have been
all my life and you know now from the
back benches I will certainly continue
to work for a liberal party that
combines a strong economy good public
services good values in the world that's
always the kind of Labor Party that I
want to see and that's what I'll do from
the back benches just finally mr.
McFadden a trident vote looms I mean is
it an issue like that that could
actually split the party I don't think
they'll be a split if you mean back in
the 1980s a sense the truth is there are
differences of opinion about some
policies we always knew that was the
case when mr. Corbin became leader and I
never made any pretence to him or to
anyone else that I agreed with him on
everything and this issue for example
hair of terrorism is one where I've
taken a strong view for years that the
West shouldn't blame itself when there
are terrorist acts that the full
responsibility for these things lies
with those who carry them out that no
one forces anyone to kill innocent
people in Paris or blow up the london
underground or any of the terrible
things that have been done and
take a very strong view of that and it's
not a matter of loyalty and say matter
of difference in substance sorry mr.
McFadden we are out of time thank you
very much indeed for yours Pat but fun